der ostergottesdienst er gehört genauso
zum fest für viele deutschen wie eben
die eiersuche und der besuch der familie
der großeltern und auch des typischen
osteressen das ist oft das osterlamm und
bei vielen natürlich der spargel doch
auf den feldern gibt es auch wegen
corona jetzt große probleme
es gibt zu wenig helfer wir sehen jetzt
hier die bilder
denn normalerweise kommen diese helfer
aus osteuropa und jetzt heute hier sehen
wir es kamen an düsseldorf eine maschine
an aus rumänien mit diesen erntehelfern
beeindruckende bilder während der korona
krise wo doch alle länder eint ihre
grenzen so dicht gemacht haben denn wir
sehen jetzt insgesamt sechs sonderflüge
sollen allein in düsseldorf landen und
auch in hamburg und berlin kamen erste
flüge nun mit erntehelfern an bei der
einreise werden diese einem
gesundheitscheck durchgezogen und es
gibt dann eine quarantäne ähnliche phase
in der sie aber bereits arbeiten dürfen
der bayerische ministerpräsident und
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
hatten sich letzte woche darauf geeinigt
dass 80.000 erntehelfer nach deutschland
fliegen dürfen im april und mai können
dann 40.000 kommen vor allem auch noch
immer für die spargelernte